foreign
Park day Dons for Africa's mightiest
meat eaters
are you ready to shift 1.2 lines on show
[Music]
have a great day
three Majestic lions
foreign
[Music]
walk their whole perimeter and scent
Mark a lot of different things this is
how Lions communicate not only with each
other but with other lion Prides in the
wild
[Music]
after they survey their surroundings
typically you'll hear them vocalize too
[Music]
is that beautiful Roar
oh
[Music]
and that's pretty typical lion Behavior
that's how they announce themselves
Kinsey's kind of got like a rasp to her
vocalization
[Music]
Kamari likes to do a quick Huff
and then Dakari
[Music]
is just big loud and Powerful
and vocalizing is one of my favorite
things in the world I've worked with him
for two years and hearing that sound
every day just gives me goosebumps
foreign
Behavior one of their favorite things to
do is Spar and play with each other
our two sisters Kenzie and Kamari really
love to see who can sneak up on the
other first
it's always been one of my biggest goals
to work with these beautiful African
carnivores and I have fallen in love
with this Pride
good morning Kamari how are you doing
today
you having a good morning
from this vantage point they can see the
entire East Savannah our bonobach our
water Buck are coming out here we have
our ostriches they definitely get really
hyped when the ostrich comes soaring by
[Music]
but at the happiest place on earth a
hidden network of moats and barriers
keeps predators and prey apart
right now we are introducing some of our
baby rhinos to the Savannah
are you excited to see the baby rhinos
come out
yeah
we have Milo Ranger and their sister
Logan coming out every day these guys
definitely keep a good watchful eye over
the Savannah when all these babies are
coming out and exploring their new
surroundings
a healthy lion needs more than just eye
candy we get bored looking at the same
stuff every single day so why wouldn't
they
they're all entering their teens which
is the geriatric stage in a big cat's
life so we really need to see how the
range of motion is functioning
just like when we get older arthritis is
a big problem
they did a hoof trim on a giraffe
yesterday we put some of those shavings
on that rock to replicate natural scents
that Lions would smell in the wild like
a giraffe just walked through their
exhibit
this is really cool to see her pawing
and clawing at that just like she would
be using those muscles to hunt and
forage in the wild
[Music]